we begin today in europe where a
national lockdown has gone into effect
in austria this is in addition to
restrictions in other countries such as
in the netherlands and belgium to
control rising case numbers primarily to
do with lower than expected vaccination
figures but these restrictions have
prompted protests and in some cases
violence such as in belgium where police
clashed with protesters on sunday there
is anger over the government's advice to
get vaccinated and any possible moves to
impose mandatory vaccinations as austria
has done
similar scenes were reported in the
netherlands which saw a third straight
night of violence
now getting people to agree to vaccinate
themselves has been hard vaccination
figures vary across europe from 67 in
germany to a little over 81 percent in
portugal and people have varying reasons
for not wanting to vaccinate against
covet 19.
we want our freedom and being injected
by something that's not tested well um
being um not able to work where you want
to work to be where you want to be
that's not what we stand for that's not
freedom that's not where we live live in
west europe and we just want to be free
like we were before it's saying
they're young people
and they've had little freedom for
almost two years now because of covet
19.
so yes i understand in a way
but i don't approve
to make a point to stand for our freedom
and to demand for more
open communication from the government
and
to to the civilians
from the politicians especially from the
scientists that they make clear stances
and be clear and fair with us and also
respect our opinion
which is
some of us we don't want to get
vaccinated
we're being put under pressure now and
ultimately we're no longer free i'll
submit to the pressure but honestly i'm
convinced mandatory vaccination is
coming
so while many in europe believe their
freedoms are compromised through
vaccination in most places in asia it's
just the opposite many believe
vaccination is the key to their freedom
which is why some nations in the region
rank among the world's best when it
comes to vaccination rates countries
like japan cambodia and malaysia
have also started reopening even as
europe starts to reclose
remember back to when the tokyo olympic
games were about to open and some
japanese
we're out on the streets saying cancel
the summer games covet 19 rates were
skyrocketing in japan and vaccination
numbers were low
fast forward to late autumn japan's
vaccination rate has finally taken off
whatever
vaccination is voluntary in japan so i
think it's a big thing that people go to
the vaccination site because they want
to receive it the inoculation completion
rate has reached about 80 percent and i
think that's the reason why
by the end of the year japan should be
near 85 vaccinated with bonus points for
an extraordinary percentage of people
wearing masks compared to much of the
rest of the world
this summer malaysia and indonesia were
battling some of the highest covet 19
case loads as the delta variant tore
through the region
both have managed to stem the surge with
malaysia now claiming 76 of its
population fully vaccinated
obviously is a lot of improvement
a lot of improvement in cambodia as well
one of the poorer countries in the
region but it's keeping up thanks to
vaccine procurement
its efforts to counter misinformation
and a general okay with old and young
getting the jab
i brought her to get vaccinated today
because i want my daughter to be free
from kovitz
also she'll be attending school soon she
shouldn't give it to her classmates nor
they to her
some nations continue to struggle india
may have hit the billion vaccination
mark but it's only 29
fully inoculated among adults
taiwan is well under 50 but the island
now has upped its game on vaccine
procurement and expects to see those
numbers rise in the coming months
and joining me now for more are
journalists michael penn in tokyo and
joyce lee from dw's east asia bureau in
taipei welcome to you both michael to
you first now japan was a slow starter
when it came to vaccinations but the
picture is very different now why
well i think this is really attributable
to the sort of japanese decision making
process and just kind of the behavior of
japanese bureaucracies in general
oftentimes they're very slow to make
decisions this is hardly unusual
to feel secure about something to
establish procedures to get everybody to
kind of agree to how to do something and
that often takes a lot longer than it
would take in most other countries but
on the other hand what japanese do very
well is after all the decisions been
made after all the buy-in is there
implementation is then smooth and
methodical and that's really what we've
seen with the vaccinations in japan slow
start but then after that just uh chugga
chugga chugga straight through to where
we are now
what about the buy-in from
the citizenry is that something that has
uh helped in the process
uh certainly uh you know uh unlike i
guess a lot of other places you know the
the whole vaccination issue whether or
not to be vaccinated
isn't really a political issue here
there's no there's no culture war divide
about you know as there is in some
countries between let's say people on
the left and people on the right about
about whether or not to get vaccinated
or not it just isn't politicized i think
most japanese kind of have a general
trust of the medical profession and so
they're uh they're willing to go along
with it maybe they didn't want to be the
first ones to get vaccinated but once
they saw that other people are getting
vaccinated and they were okay
they were okay to go and get vaccinated
themselves
joyce to you in taipei now the taiwanese
were also hesitant to vaccinate
themselves especially in the summer
what's the situation now
well um
almost 50 of the population are fully
vaccinated now and that's a huge leap
compared to uh what happened in the
summer before the major outbreak
happened in may people were
very hesitant and
they were very concerned about the side
effects of the vaccines especially when
there was simply
almost no covet in taiwan at that time
so uh people didn't feel the urgency to
get vaccinated and even the government
the authority said that there was no
hurry to purchase vaccines because uh
the containment of the virus had been so
successful at that time but after the
major outbreak in may people were very
scared of getting infected and
they start
they started to once you get vaccinated
and desperate for vaccines so the number
is going up now and
the supply of vaccines is also getting
better now
talk to us a bit about the role of the
government here in trying to convince
people to get vaccinated and the reason
i ask this is because here in europe at
least governments have been unable to
convince large numbers of people to
follow restrictions or for that matter
get themselves vaccinated
well it's not that hard for the
government to convince people to follow
the rules and the restrictions uh
because um we we should uh not ignore
the cultural nuance uh here in taiwan or
in chinese society there's a saying that
goes uh sacrifice oneself for the
greater good uh for the society so um
it's a collectivist uh society here in
taiwan and uh
people are more willing to sacrifice
their freedom
or their interests in order to protect
the people around them and bear in mind
that taiwanese experienced the sas
outbreak in 2003 so wearing a mask
was uh very taken for granted um
uh
even before the mass mandate taiwanese
people were rushing to uh convenience
stores to get their mosque uh to protect
themselves and the people around them
and wearing a mask not wearing a mask is
like not wearing pens in public nowadays
so and there's a peer pressure in taiwan
that if you don't
follow what the majority people do
you kind of get weird looks from others
so uh this is the cultural uh side of um
uh what we're facing here in taiwan
uh michael to you in tokyo uh joyce was
just talking about the cultural nuance
essentially the shame almost
if you don't wear if you're not wearing
a mask it's akin to not wearing pants i
mean is that something that one could
apply to japan as well which would sort
of explain uh why japan has been able to
control uh kovit 19 much better
particularly after the olympics
yeah almost everything joyce said there
uh applies with almost equal force with
japan uh you know the culture uh
believes in in cooperation and doing
things for the community much as she uh
outlined in taiwan uh maybe the only two
differences would be
that uh you know we didn't have the sars
outbreak here so there wasn't uh that uh
and also that uh you know there was also
not a really a lull in the covid
outbreak we have had five waves here in
japan which have been pretty consistent
so uh whereas she said taiwan is about
fifty percent vaccinated here in japan
we're close to eighty percent vaccinated
one i think it's perhaps the highest
rate among g7 or g
countries as far as i know but anyway uh
it's uh it's gone forward steadily and
it continues i mean even though the
rates of daily vaccinations is down
that's probably just because we're
getting to the parts of the population
where very few people need to be
vaccinated among 65 and olders
it's 92 percent of the japanese
population is now vaccinated
i mean numbers that people in uh europe
will only be jealous of i have to ask
you michael we don't have much time left
but how do people in japan view what's
happening in europe in terms of the
protests and the violence that one is
seeing against against
government measures and restrictions
well honestly i imagine most japanese
kind of shrug at it and kind of say well
that there's foreigners being violent
again i mean there's kind of this
feeling in japan that that oversees
people you know make trouble and make
hassles over things that they don't
really need to make hassles over so i
think they probably look at it and say
yep those are the foreigners that's what
they do you know good thing we don't
have that here
journalist michael penley in tokyo and
dw correspondent joyce lee in taipei
thanks very much both of you for joining
us today